What is this going to be about?
Brainstormed some Ideas.
Also we contacted concept artists.
Started putting together some rough text
and rough imagery.
Even actually went as far as casting
a mini, fake teaser for the peace.
Which was mostly just cool graphics.
and cool people posing on greenscreens
with guns.
The whole point of all this was just to prove
we know how we wanna, kind of
play our characters and, not to mention
hey, look at how cool this stuff looks
if we did it in live action too!
There's a way Sam and I came at it.
We're inspired by the multiplayer of Battlefeild
-Yeah
I mean it has its single player campaign but,
Realistically
The vast majority of people spend their time
playing the multiplayer.
You just have to realize at its core
that is what you have to embrace
when you're gonna design a piece
based off a video game is the common experience.
When you pitch a video game project
It's the hardest thing to figure out
alright what is the angle we're gonna hit this with,
you know.
A lot of video game projects in the past I think
go wrong, because they are
A: Sticking to main characters in these story lines
and trying to recreate them.
B: They're trying to 100% recreate.
like settings or memorable/iconic things from the game.
or they completely deviate all together
into a mass audience that has nothing to do with the game.
Yeah! I mean, at that point.
but the thing is that
at that point no matter which option you take
you're like pigeon holing youself
into these like
pre-writen, pre-made, you know, linear things that.
honestly
players have already experienced.
Well another issue too is
-Yeah.
a lot of companies have this ideal of what their game is.
that doesn't line up with what the public perceives it as.
-Exactly.
You know its like, they want their game to be this.
So they make all their marketing like this.
and they make all their official stuff like this but,
the public doesn't see the game that way.
and you get this weird mashup at times.
and we've dealt with that when we've done
our various brand integrations on the channel.
It's a very serious war game.
there's no jokes, so to speak about it.
Its, this is was, this is battle.
It's 100% gritty and 100% serious.
and then you flip that around
and you take a look at all the videos online of
gamers who are playing it. (ourselves included)
and usually it is...
you putting a bomb on some guys butt
when he's not looking and blowing him up.
you know so thats
a lot closer to the actual common experience
and so you kind of have to recognize that
basically just have to balance both worlds a little bit.
Everything in terms of just a general shooting style
like how we like to actually get things done.
We have a certain way of operating on set
and so our goal was to take what we've learned
with low budget micro crew film making
and see how we can apply the best parts of that
to a larger film crew.
Yeah, that's definitely an interesting challenge
and if you're running around
shooting with your friends
and you're getting millions of views on the internet
do you really need to change that?
If you move on to a different styled project
the answer is yes.
-Yes.
*laughter*
Yup and more on that as you watch the behind the scenes.
"RUSH" is finally live!
and if you're in the US you can go to
Go90.com right now and watch episodes 1 & 2
for FREE!
It's super cool, everyone's diggin' it.
Check it.